hello everyone and welcome back
we're glad that you can join us for a
very exciting panel discussion with some
on the eve of the industry
leading experts in forensic science and
criminal justice
it's my pleasure to introduce professor
wilton parson who will be our moderator
for this morning panel discussion and
who will be introducing
the the panel experts before we go along
for remember that for the full listing
of details of the panelists please
click on the tab that you have on the
top of your screen and for sure if you
have any questions
during the presentation we encourage you
to submit them in the q a box
and we will try our best to take as many
questions as possible during the session
and with that please join me in
welcoming professor walter parson and
the panelist
walter the floor is yours
thank you very much chevy hello
everybody good morning
from innsbruck austria
i'm looking forward to this panel
discussion that we are going to have
together
we are going to discuss how to maximize
the impacts of forensic dna
and we have 45 minutes for that and
you're invited to
actively participate in this so please
ask questions use the tool
we try to accommodate your questions if
it's impossible we can
tackle them later we have a wonderful
panel that i would like to briefly
introduce to you before we start the
discussion
we have a victim advocate vanessa lynch
she's coming in from south africa those
of you who were on the car earlier
saw her presentation she's a founder of
the dna project
in the dna project africa which are both
non-profit organizations and dedicated
to the use of advocacy outreach and
forensic expertise
to aid the development of databasing in
the forensic dna scales in
the countries throughout africa
we have investigators class for flute
and
stephanie van silen class is uh
with the dutch police for more than 40
years he gave a presentation today
earlier as well
he has uh best experience in forensic
investigations and support
investigations in serious and major
national international crime classes
actually pioneered the efforts in
implementing rapid dna
technology already in 2013.
stephanie's background is researching
cancer
she just joined the national police
laboratory in 2019
her current role is focusing focused on
the implementation of the applied
biosystems reputed id
our forensic expert is silver evac
is uh calling in from france silva has a
phd in uh
molecular biology and in uh genetics
he joined the national channel marie in
2004
and he is basically performing research
development and validation of methods
for forensic laboratory analysis
silva was directly involved in the
identification of the victims of the
german wings air crash in 2015
and the 2016 terrorist attack in nice
which i think it's all still in our
memories
and then we have our legal expert chris
asplin he's calling in from the u.s
he's a very early bird it's uh 5 a.m in
in the us at this time
chris thanks for doing this chris is the
executive director of the national
criminal justice association he serves
as a principal liaison between the state
and local
units in the government and various
agencies of the us government
he has assisted the development of
curricular interiors
for convenings of more than 35
international governments both in
bratislava slovakia
and the international peace palace in
the hague the netherlands
so before we draw the
attention to our discussion i would like
to remind you again
please use this format and ask questions
we decided to dedicate this discussion
into
three major topics
trying to shed light on the maximization
of impact of forensic dna
and i would like to start with the topic
that is central to all forensic analysis
and that is the evidence that's the
evidence that we find at the crime scene
and that we try to analyze
so how can we make this analysis more
effective and for that i would like to
start with our critics in the
netherlands
please tell us what is the evidence
material that you are typically
confronted with
and what are the challenges that you are
facing with those
materials
okay most important evidence
or samples we take is blood
and saliva so for dna
but also fingerprint symbols in every
sample heterocrime scene
but for the rapid dna and that's our
challenge
is to start with a rapid dna i told you
before
there is a big problem to start with
rapidly in the netherlands we have to
take
many steps for to be operational
and i think
maybe in one month we can start really
because the law is changing
and the other problems are solved and we
can start with operational cases only
for saliva and blood
but we did the test before with the
rapid
hit and we know that a pulled hair
also gives you a good result but
until now it's validated for blood and
saliva
cigarette butts and everything and only
for various cases for right now
so we cannot use the machine for other
cases other than
terrorism right now
sorry what you just said class uh uh
stephanie makes uh makes good sense and
uh
probably the audience is wondering um if
you can share more details how you are
going to
implement uh the the rapid dna
technology in terms of uh where do you
locate it
we all know the netherlands is a small
country so distance is from crime scenes
to laboratories may not be that large
as they would be in other countries
uh but apparently you are already pretty
advanced with this technology so so can
you please
give us more insight on this
okay uh in my presentation maybe you saw
it
you can see that uh it takes
days or sometimes weeks to have a dna
analyze and to be ready and look in the
database
and we look to speed up this process so
we built the rapid hit in in a van
and the idea was to go to a crime scene
so to shorten this time of investigation
and to make uh the decision by the
forensic investigator themselves okay
this else
this is really a simple i can use this
is really a sample of a perpetrator
i can put it in my rapid hit and have
the
the results back in a few hours so that
was very important to shorten this time
when we bring it to a laboratory that's
normally our national forensic institute
it's a preferred lab
it will do the the investigation also
quickly
four till six hours but we think
when you are on the crime scene and as a
police
officer i can tell you we know sometimes
[Music]
we are a little bit quicker at the crime
scene already
and we have to choose after your
investigation directly
the the sample you can use not like
normal
normally i did a lot of cases normal it
takes
maybe the whole day when you have a
murder case to investigate it
all right
sorry go ahead as stephanie told you
for us it was very important in
terrorist cases and also serious and
organized crime cases
to to be sure we are uh
we have the right guy so uh not
do all the things uh with other police
officers maybe civilians or everything
else
and having the wrong uh suspect
so that's important to identify him uh
very soon okay so i understand
it's the response time that is critical
and uh
i think that is that is uh the case and
has been observed in
in a couple of other scenarios
uh what comes to my mind is the the
quick response time that they were
trying to get
with the disasters in france silva
you were elemental in uh trying to
identify
victims and for the german wing crash
and the the the terrorists in the
nice attack can you share uh your
opinion
in terms of response time and the use of
the rapid dna technology for that
yeah for in in my institute we have
approached for rapid dna technology
because
the definition of rapid dna is very
compact
compact instrument where you can process
all the steps in
all in one instrument but for
dvi context for example during
the terrorist attacking nice or during
the air crash
german wings there is too many samples
to analyze
simultaneously and that's why rapid dna
technology
for this moment uh the throughput is not
enough to
to give the good response to the
investigation so that's why we have a
different approach for the rocket dna
and for the mobile lab technologies so
we developed
uh it's like a van okay but we
integrate in that in this band all the
regular materials that you use
in your in your lab so basically we use
some regular thermocycle regular extract
extraction method and search 500 in
excel also
and by this way we can process
we can process 96 samples simultaneously
so by this way we can obtain generators
of many many fragments of unknown bodies
and it's very is very efficient in this
case
thank you uh we got a question in here
which i
i think fits very nice the topic um
it's about the uh the ability of uh
detecting single versus mixed profiles
with the
rapid dna technology so the
the question actually is how can you
tell if the blood stain taken from the
crime scene is single source
or once a mixture is seen how how would
you continue
and that is open to the entire panelists
so
feel free to chime in
so the question is if you have a what do
you do if you have single source of
mixture
right i mean the sort of question is if
you have a mixed sample
and you can tell up front right because
you don't know if it's a mixture or not
you see it when you analyze it
so what what is the reaction once you
have once you see the mixture are you
analyzing the mixture with the rapid hit
or are you what are the further steps if
you see a mixture
we um we analyze the data with uh with
gene mapper and we can
use also or other other software like
exterior mix
so we in fact when you have to
to deal with with rapid technology we
use regular
regular workflow
all right so you use i understand you
use the profile that comes from the
rapid
dna instrument and the used software
to be able to interpret the the the
mixture as it would come from a regular
ce instrument
yeah uh vanessa
klaus would you class would you like to
answer this or stephanie
yes so uh if we would suspect that a
sample is a mixture we wouldn't run it
on the
rapid hits system but we would send it
to the national
forensic institute
a way of knowing or
deciding whether it might be a mixture
or not is to
look at the scenario what's going on
what happened how many people were
involved
how likely is it that there is a mixture
mixture of this sample
but that will be analyzed before we get
the sample
so um there's a team of people that
actually decide
this is probably a mixture or this is
probably not a mixture
if it's a single source they will give
it to us if it's not
then they will send it to the national
forensic
institute i have one more question here
which i would like to
bring up to the panel what different
sample sources can be analyzed by rapid
and uh i repeat that class was saying
that in the netherlands you intend to
use it for blood samples and saliva
right
would you like to add other information
to that
yes we are fixing the rapidity
in my lab actually and uh so we
we deal with different kind of centers
uh of course blood centers
uh butts but also we test
some some fragment of bones so
it works very very good with fresh bones
and
for that we developed a specific meter
to
to collect to collect bonds and directly
the fragment of bonds inside the
cartridge
and we we obtained a very very good
result with that
great thank you very much uh and then
another question that fits very well so
let's take it and
maybe we can provide a very quick answer
what is the sensitivity of rapid dna
testing so how less how few dna
would provide a useful result
the result obtained from uh deleted
blood
uh is you you can obtain a full dna
profile
from brow diluted one to one to fifty
one one hundred
but well you can consider 20 microliter
of blood on the onscreen
and you deal with one to one two fifteen
to one hundred and you can obtain a
virginia profile
all right thank you uh class stephanie
did you do any particular sensitivity
experiments on the
on the rapid hit that that seems to be a
general questions from the audience
so i haven't been working on the rapid
hit 200
system for the sensitivity but i'm
working on it
for the rapid hit id and i'm actually
planning on
testing the sensitivity next week so i
don't have any data on that yet so
fantastic so all those who are
interested please contact stephanie in
one week or
give her another week then she will have
the answers for that
all right you know if we take a closer
look at the interplay
of the of the case for example that we
are trying to
uh improve in terms of their the
analytics
and the actual identification process
what are the challenges there
uh and and i would like to um
bring our discussion more into the how
into the point how we using the dna
information
in order to uh find the criminals
and that is particularly addressing the
databasing system
uh vanessa you have uh outlined the um
situation in africa quite well
would you like to speak to this
situation for
a third world country and and tell the
challenges that you see there
thank you walter um yes i think the
there's a misconception that once you
pass a dna law
or dna laws that you can
launch into identifying and convicting
criminals
and it requires a lot more commitment
and this is where the challenges really
come into play
the first is funding a lot of
governments don't understand
that the commitment to this technology
requires a huge amount of funding for
consumables for maintenance and for
sampling
and this is something we've hit in south
africa is that they've withdrawn a lot
of this funding with the
um with the result that the
initial growth of the database has now
been greatly reduced because the funding
has been withdrawn
so i think that is something that if
developing countries are looking at
passing dna laws or in the process of it
is really to ensure that the government
or the administration
understands the financial commitment um
because you you know maybe don't invest
too much in the capital and maybe
have a smaller investment which makes
sure that the consumables are funded
going forward otherwise you just land up
with um
big forensic laboratories that aren't
actually working which is
currently where we facing a situation
like that um and the second
challenge which you mentioned is
actually once you have your database in
place and you actually are analyzing and
loading profiles onto the database
how does that translate into convictions
how does it translate into identifying
offenders
and this is the follow-up what we call
the follow-up of investigative leads
that are issued from the dna laboratory
and oftentimes um the the people at the
ground level who
are the task force the police sport
don't have a
very good understanding of what a dna
profile means
in terms of the value so these
wonderful forms of evidence these
wonderful hits and
investigative leads are left lying on
the desk because they probably
are not necessarily given to the task
force in a language that they understand
so
we need to really look at how are we
translating this information to ground
level in order for them to understand
the real value of what it
is that a dna profile has there's been a
hit on the database
and we've just recently insta
instituted task team so we've got
specialized task teams on south african
r
and all they do is they receive the hits
from the database manager
and they work in teams to make sure that
those are followed up especially when
you have more than one
hit per person um so those are the
greatest two challenges and there
are lots of others that possibly other
developing countries
might consider when when ensuring that
they are
you know making sure that it translates
into convictions or crime resolution
thank you very much what do you have
been referring to
is probably uh true for many countries
even
if we want to call them first-world
countries i'm not sure if this is a good
term to use
but the the follow-up of the
[Music]
the actual dna match to
the to the executive forces that
actually then
tries to solve the crime seems to me a
problem that is
a general problem all over the world so
we i understand with the
uh the dna project you are trying to
provide
um information that can be applied to
different countries it's not only
uh for africa
yes we've got you know the the thing is
that
we specifically realize now with this
pandemic the world is actually a small
place and it's very easy to communicate
with each other and um one of the things
that is really striking is that
when you have information available to
yourself
it's it's a great benefit to share it
with other countries specifically where
you have gone through
problems and where you can share your
challenges and work together
so in south africa it's it's been an
enormous struggle because we have first
of all technology
technology in a developing country um
but we didn't reinvent the wheel
we we really did um from the dna project
side
lincoln with a lot of other countries
and leaders in this field in order to
help us
produce the results that we have had and
and will continue to have challenges so
by the same token south africa and the
dna project wants to reach out into
africa and other developing countries to
say don't reinvent the wheel
look at what we've done talk to us about
privacy challenges
challenges we've just spoken about now
legislative legislative
recommendations and and this is
something we really want to
assist other countries uh we don't have
to start from scratch
you know let's utilize the information
that we have collectively
and try and find solutions that fit into
different countries
looking for solutions
thank you vanessa um chris
your expertise goes beyond the situation
of
databasing in the us as you have been
involved in
different scenarios worldwide would you
like to speak to this
in addition to what vanessa said
sure thank you walter there are
a lot of different collateral
consequences that come along with
databasing
as vanessa mentioned that really need to
be
anticipated when passing legislation
um including the funding again as
vanessa said
one thing i'll add to that for example
is
you will necessarily when passing
legislation and just by the nature of
increasing
your database and the size of the
database there will be
add-on applications that police the
public and other folks will want for
example
what we saw in the united states was the
emergence of
cold case units all over the country
once we had a database and we
realized that there was a great value to
going back and looking at old cases
taking taking biological samples testing
and putting them in the database
well that created essentially a whole
new market a whole new community of
folks that wanted to
use the database well one of the
collateral consequences in that is
how do you deal with victims how do you
deal with victims who
may have put this case behind them 10
years ago but but now the police
are are essentially bringing it back to
life and solving it
um there are a lot of resources that
necessarily have to go into
um that aspect of solving a cold case
you have
another collateral consequence for
example we saw in the united states was
defense attorneys wanting to to leverage
the database
because they would say that their client
was innocent but if they were able to
test the database
that they could then prove that so
anticipating
those collateral consequences when
considering
databasing legislation is is really
super important to maximize its
effectiveness
thank you chris um i i have a question
here which probably fits to
what we just discussed and this question
uh relates to the to the approach
of low of being able of loading a crime
scene
profile onto the database in order to do
the database search
uh it is probably quite a
challenging question particularly if we
consider technology and not only
technology but also legal aspects
but the background of the question
apparently seems to be
the you know the attempt to minimize
errors and the problems that are
associated with bringing the samples
from the crime scene to the laboratory
performing the analysis in the
laboratory and then finally
uploading the profile which goes through
many hands of the individuals
is anybody at this panel willing to
speak to that
question about what would be the way
forward in the different aspects of
trying to look at
crime scene profits already from the
crime scene
so uh with our van
we actually are at the crime scene so we
get our sample
we run uh the rapid hit machine and then
we have a secure
network that allows us to directly send
our sample into the database
so we have a really quick
[Music]
line yeah it's it's a quick uh
line for us to do that
thank you very much uh stephanie uh
how is the situation with that inc in
the u.s chris
you know
um we have um over i guess
the last 10 or 15 years we have put a
tremendous
amount of effort into training and
education
for our law enforcement uh in terms of
collection transportation
etc um so while it's it's always an
issue that
you have to be you know top of mind of
if you will and
and that has to be kind of a priority i
don't think
we find terribly often that that is a
difficulty or a problem
that being said the opportunity and the
availability
of doing of doing dna testing
closer to the crime scene and more
importantly closer in time to the crime
right that really maximizes the
potential of the technology
the the closer you get to both the crime
scene and to the time of the event of
the crime the more you're maximizing the
potential of the technology
all right thank you very much um
we have a question here uh that is a
very um
interesting question it comes from the
city of karachi in pakistan
they have the problem
that they don't have a database yet so
for uh
can the pendle speak to potential
solutions for the situation if there is
a crime or if there is the requirement
of forensic dna typing
and then in the lack of the database
to to solve issues i mean that goes back
to
situations where we didn't have a dna
databases either
what what could be a recommendation to a
country that does not have a
functioning dna database yet in order to
be able to solve
crimes or to to provide investigative
leads on crimes
that are in this situation
vanessa maybe you can speak to this
hi walter sorry i have to say i think it
was a bit of a dodgy wi-fi
um moment there in terms of your um
actual question so um do you want me to
just repeat that last part
sorry yeah um we have a case from
a country that doesn't have a dna
database yet and uh
crime happened in the city of karachi in
pakistan they
wonder what steps they can take in to
try to make use of dna profiles prior to
being able to search it in a dna
database
is there is there an idea that you can
speak to
yes interestingly enough we have a
separate unit for
disaster victim identification and
missing persons
and even though now those
profiles are loaded onto the database
they do have their own
sort of mini database where they where
they collate those profiles
and in fact they use rapid dna
technology in that particular department
which is the only department that uses
it um so
i think that the collection of dna
profiles
for a specific purpose will always be
allowed to to some
extent or the other and when we got our
dna laws and we translated those
profiles
we that we then were able to formally
put those profiles into the database
within the confines of the laws so if
there were any profiles that didn't
fall within the um
the provisions of the law for instance
if it was um
over a certain amount of time or a
particular category of person
they weren't allowed to be on their
database but there was value
nevertheless
in keeping those profiles for all that
time until such time laws were in place
in which case
they were then translated into a
database
but um i think there's always value
in in retaining profiles as far as
possible
and i think that in this particular case
[Music]
i would imagine that they would possibly
be able to do that under a separate
system of disaster victim identification
and missing persons where there's always
a possibility of later identification
i'm not sure if
anyone else adds to that or if they've
had a similar
situation walter if i could add to that
um if we go back to the original
the first case where dna was ever used
in a forensic context right that was
also the first time
that we used intelligence screens
and and intelligence screens and and
they're still widely used
they are essentially the creation of
many databases um
absent the legislation necessary to
create that larger database
but what it does allow police and
laboratories to do is to focus on a
particular area
or a particular demographic and leverage
dna technology in what we would simply
call a smaller database
that doesn't have to be legislatively
created and and
and you don't even need the software for
that right i mean that could be a
spreadsheet
it's a little more labor intensive but
the leveraging
of intelligence screens voluntarily
asking for volunteers etc
is uh is a technique that that has been
used literally
since day one of forensic dna testing um
and and continues to be used today that
being said we
need to be careful with it and that that
the lack of legislation
um can lead to violation of people's
rights that
that's why legislation is important so i
think if police are going to use
intelligence screens
that they need to do it with a real eye
towards
human rights and civil rights but it's a
it's a very valid tool still used all
over the world
thanks chris that's that's great and and
and that's perfect perfectly preparing
the floor
for a question that i would like to pick
here
comes from israel and the question is
who is responsible for the analysis of
the profile
the user in the field or an expert
back in the database laboratory database
so that is a legal question probably we
have different
answers depending on the country but i
would like to invite the panda to try to
answer this chris you want to give it a
start
well sure i'll tell you the way that
that rapid dna in particular
is shaping up in the united states is
that
while law enforcement is allowed to
use it and i say aloud specifically
because we had to change some of our
laws
that allowed for police to use rapid dna
outside the context
of the laboratory prior to that prior to
federal legislation changing that what
we call a booking station or police
station model wasn't possible
but but now it is but that profile
while it may be tested and it may be
analyzed in a rapid hit
in the in the police station or you know
in a van somewhere
that ultimately still goes that result
still goes to the to the laboratory
still goes to the codus lab and it is
still evaluated at that point in time
so the answer to your question is both
in the united states
it necessarily needs to be both the
the police officer responsible on the
scene or a crime scene analyst
and then the lad
thanks chris yes please
in france it's uh it's very different
because
there is only a dnx dna experts that
are able to to upload a dna profile
database and able to analyze the
expert must be certified by the curve
and even if there is a heat for example
on a database
the it must be confirmed by the dna
experts
so the guys on the field are not able to
interpret the results
they are just able to collect the
evidences but not integrate
thank you very much i was assuming that
there are different
uh answers to that question and
apparently our discussions triggered a
new question which i would like to put
up here
um and and it asks we should be
we should be more clear about what the
database is
so in case those uh countries that they
don't have a database do we
and i'm i'm reading the question here do
we have to create
the dna database of all the citizens or
just
from the crime guys and i like the
expression crime guys very much
what what can we answer in terms of um
what kind of samples would populate
an intelligence database
it's only a relevant traces of course
for example in france we have to deal
with
many many touch dna samples
and in this case it's very important to
be
to be aware that if you collect um
in everywhere in each support you can
obtain a dna of course but
what kind of dna you obtain do you
obtain the dna of the
perpetrators or the dna of the victim
and most of time if you collect that dna
for example for burglaries cases
you collect the dna of the victim and if
you are not able to
discriminate this dna profile
before to load this profile inside the
database so
you are in your database with many many
dna profiles victims and not suspect
i i i would i would say that one thing
to be careful of
is to not develop your
your database the way the united states
did it initially
we did it wrong um we made the mistake
of when we first started databasing we
only included
the most serious crimes um and
for our offender index only the most
serious criminals
but that's really not the way to do it
because the most serious criminals when
they get convicted they go to jail for a
long time they're not out you're not
solving their crimes
the important thing to do is to include
in your database
individuals who are convicted or accused
of
high-volume crimes like burglary
burglars commit a lot of burglaries
car thefts car thieves commit commit a
lot of car thefts
drug dealers they do that a lot and
making sure that you are um
leveraging dna on those high volume
crimes
and i'm not saying don't include
murderers and rapists you should
but if you're going to maximize your the
power of your dna database
you want to make sure you include those
individuals
who commit their crimes a lot high
volume high impact crimes
which we did not do in the united states
and it took us a long time to change the
law again
and again and again in every state
before we got to the point where we were
really maximizing the potential
if i can add to that um we in south
africa
went a little a little bit further than
that we created a schedule of offences
which which ranged from most serious
uh violent crimes down to burglary and
faith but we also left after number of
crimes
um so we called it a schedule eight
crimes
um the problem was with that
was actually the administrative burden
of sifting through
what type of crime it was so even though
they left off things like drunken
driving um
it was still it was still a process of
having to sort through it both from
convictor and
convicted offenders and arrestees so
whilst the reason was initially
to not overburden the forensic science
laboratories with too many samples of
minor crimes
what they landed up doing was actually
making it burdensome
to continuously have to sift through
whether this should be included or
expunged or
um you know sampled and so i think that
chris just to add to yours both from
you know an administrative as well as a
criminal career path
um it is much better to have as many
as many types of all types of crimes and
not discriminate between them
for obvious reasons
yes thank you very much quite a complex
scenario that we're looking at um
i in the interest of time i would like
to move on
uh there are a couple of questions which
i cannot address so please apologize the
audience
you will have the possibility to get
those um
and those questions answered after our
communication
i would like to carry on to
alternative methods that we use to
narrow down
the pool of our suspects i mean
databasing is an intelligence
tool primarily that tries to find
suspects if we can't find a hit in the
database
then there are different options
to reduce the pool of the potential
suspects
and we all are aware of these key words
that we
have here one is investigative genetic
genealogy
which is very much centered in the us
ancestry testing and phenotyping
which i understand is more performed in
the
european or eurasian world i would like
to say
can i can i ask the panel to uh
to speak to this uh and maybe we
start with the genetic genealogy chris
if you wanna sketch the situation real
quick
uh what is going on there in the u.s
yeah sure
so um in the u.s like um as
in most if not all of the dna
applications
in the united states it's very state
specific our system is such that
the individual states they create their
own legislation
that decides what kind of dna can be
used and how big the database is
um consistent with overall federal
regulations but the states decided so
so there are actually some states in the
united states that do not allow for
example
what we refer to as familial testing or
close match testing
there are some states that have made the
the political decision that
that if there is a family member in a
database
that it is not fair or consistent with
privacy rights that someone else should
be
allowed to be identified in the database
that they become suspects if you will
that's not really true but that's the
political dynamic under which the
decisions are made
so um so again from a genealogy
standpoint
goes back to it's really important to
create
good legislation to be thoughtful about
the legislation
and and in doing so bring the public
into that
have the discu have the public
understand what's going on
the the thing that maximizes and and and
affects the the power of dna the most is
what the law allows you to do with it
doesn't matter how good your rapid
technology is it doesn't matter how good
your crime scene
collection is if the law doesn't allow
you to use it
so paying attention to that and and
we're going through this on a
state-by-state basis
with genealogy testing for example um is
all part of that
and and we need to do more of it in the
united states there are probably a
handful of states that are doing it
not not nearly as many as should
thanks and uh your explanation just
triggered the question which i think
matches perfectly in here um should we
invest
more in kinship analysis slash forensic
genealogy to maximize the
rate of solved crimes i mean we hear the
success story in the media we hear those
investigative leads that you know
brought us the perpetrator and
sometimes it's code cases 25 years ago
so that's great news
can you say something about the
efficiency of this method how many of
those investigations go code
and what is the situation in that
respect
yeah i i don't know how many um
of those cases go cold i i don't know
how many kinship cases
are successful versus how many are not
um
i i do know that oftentimes they're used
in
the most um um
serious of cases right and so when we
get a hit and it's all
it's a very big matter in the united
states as it should be right
and so i think the analysis is more a
matter of
of the value of the particular hits is
contrasted with
the volume of hits that we get but again
it's a very political matter um and
and and if you've turned on the
television in the last three weeks
you've seen that in the united states
we're having some difficulty
um rethinking our relationship with law
enforcement
and and what that means um and
this will be part of it it's not right
now um
but this discussion will be part of what
goes on as
as again united states begins to to
rethink
that relationship with law enforcement
thank you very much chris um let's turn
this back to europe
uh europe is um
has some very few successful cases
or implementations of this but as a
matter of fact the database sciences are
just too small
but i think we in europe we can speak
for
successes in uh using alternative
technology like dna phenotyping and
ancestry testing
class uh stephanie would you like to
to speak to this particularly with the
experience you made in the netherlands
i think you were pioneering this this
kind of work
yeah now i i have no experience with the
databases i know
uh we are sending out data to the
national forensic institute and i know
they
use all the possibilities for familiar
searching in ship
ancestry everything so that's possible
and i know some cases they work with but
i have no
experience myself with
analyzing data and everything else we
did have a few um
big cold cases that were solved using
um a dna analysis where
a familiar family or
hit was generated sorry
uh and uh by doing more research they
they found the the actual uh
criminal uh in those cases so we did
have some
some really good successes with uh
those type of investigations
right and if i remember correctly it's
it's finding the perpetrator on on one
side but
taking out the the extreme
chaotic situation when for example
minorities are considered to be
hosting the the suspect and all the
social situation that is going on when
uh
we think about refugees that uh may fall
under suspicion
in terms of those crimes and i think uh
some lessons were learned there in the
netherlands that uh
work very well for the rest of the world
in terms of how to approach
how to strategically approach uh these
investigations and
and i i understand from their experience
that
the ancestry testing was very
informative
as well as the phenotype analysis
in france silva
how is the situation there i'm sure
you're performing research in this
direction
what is the legal situation in france
and
probably you can talk about the
difficulties in trying to
use ancestry or phenotypic information
uh yeah in france so it's it's very new
so
uh punitive phenotype investigation
phenotyping investigation are very
limited
and basically we use this type of
technology
when all the regular techniques are
are failed and there is a
very important part of
individual freedom in france and that's
that's why
it's it's for the moment very difficult
to
to implement uh more this kind of uh
kind of technology but we we use it we
use it
when all the regular technique gave
a negative result or not an efficient
reason
thank you very much silva i just
realized how how time flies
um i would like to come back and
and open the the view and the picture
that we are discussing here and talk
more about the
the public and the political challenges
that we face
related to casework and dna databasing
and i would like to invite you vanessa
uh to speak to this particularly
you know the keyword the evolution of
the administration
be it a database result from a
conventional dna analysis be it
a new technology that creates this
this result you have been addressing
this
earlier but would you like to expand on
this
what are the the the challenges that we
are going to
face once we have set up these systems
in order to be able to get them going
thanks walter yes i think the um
important thing is to evolve not only
your legislation but
your legislation must evolve with the
technology and
um my my advice would be
certainly in passing legislation don't
go for perfect legislation
i think start whatever legislation you
are able to get with your administration
and we all have different privacy laws
and we all have different
local challenges but certainly once you
have
dna laws in place make sure that
at least every three to five years that
you have a system in place whereby you
can make recommendations back to the
policy holders
in terms of changes that need to be made
and this is something that we've just
done five years after our legislation
we've seen to dna report to our
parliament
and we've made recommendations for
changes to the legislation
some of which haven't worked that need
to be altered and other new
recommendations
which are aligned with the technology um
that you know we talk about genealogy
that didn't exist at the time our
legislation was passed
so it's very important to have a um
a process or a system in place in our
case it was an oversight body
that allows the legislation not to
remain stagnant
um that it is that there's a facility
that enables the legislation
to evolve together with this technology
which is moving at such a fast rate
okay i mean for the majority of us that
are not
familiar with legal with the involvement
of legal
uh the legal situation i think this is
an important information and
it comes to my mind that what we need to
do is we need to network not only
between the scientists that we are
probably used to when it comes to our
methods and technologies but expand
this networking and i don't want to use
the term lobbying but it's
it's kind of sharing information and
speaking to a to another field
so the experience that you have here
seems to be quite good
definitely and um again it's about
understanding that not all of our
circumstances are going to be the same
but certainly there is always going to
be overlap and learning from
others we can decide which information
is relevant and which we can take
forward
and that applies to all of us but we
have the ability now to network
and solve crime together and i think
it's something that we really need to
launch into
going forward it's something we haven't
done in the past that we need to do more
of it now going forward
thank you very much um let's ring us a
question
which is which has some legal background
and probably
also results in what we just said before
who can order dna tests first off
who can order dna tests uh i would be
interested
if the panel can give short answers to
that question
in the respective countries um chris do
you want to
give that one a start sure in the united
states
the legislation determines who is
included in the database so
um and again that's on a state basis so
the state law
um determines what offenders get um
tested for have their dna put into the
database whether it's
convicted offenders what crimes or
arrests these
and then the police um decide what they
are going to collect and put into the
database and test themselves
there are guidelines from the fbi etc
but for the most part
it is guided by legislation in terms of
the offenders and that's
uh that's really critical
thank you very much um
say saying say it again please silva
yeah to be sure
it's the same in france okay thank you
walter um this is chevy this is really
super
interesting but i have to unfortunately
say that we have to
finish the the session otherwise we will
not give the
delegates the option to the next session
with team and the heat of the year so
um well thank you thank you very much to
you and the panelists i mean maybe you
can say a couple words uh
walter to finish if you want um
but this has been really amazing i think
that the interconnection between all of
you has been great the flow of the
the presentation and all the many
questions we've got so just a friendly
reminder that we will resume
um and capture all these questions
collect them all send them to the to the
panelists get the answers and we will
post them in the on-demand version of
this that is going to be actually
available after the session but we'll
update it with all these questions
just say big thank you walter chris
vanessa class stephanie
silva this has been an amazing job today
thank you very much thank you very much
uh
i would like to thank the entire panel
and
also the audience for putting the many
questions uh this is exciting
45 minutes passed like like this
for hosting this and i hope to see you
all in
a real world soon thanks thank you very
much
thank you very much